bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat dans quelques instants
vous allez pouvoir suivre l'examen de la
proposition de loi tendant à abroger le
bouclier fiscal à mes côtés pour en
parler le sénateur thierry foucaud
bonjour alors vous êtes l'auteur de
cette proposition de loi
vous appelez les consciences éveillées
de ces milliers de manifestants à passer
aux travaux pratiques est ce que vous
entendez par là exactement bien à passer
aux travaux pratiques
bon on aime bien vu que dans les
manifestes dans les manifestations
beaucoup de manifestants demandaient
justement la suppression de ce bouclier
fiscal pourquoi parce que le bouclier
fiscal c'est 458 9 458 millions d'euros
qui profite à 14000 personnes des
privilégiés bien sûr 94 mille personnes
sur quatre cent cinquante huit mille
euros c'est 33000 euros par personne et
pour toucher 33000 euros il faut déjà
avoir un patrimoine conséquent
d'ailleurs certains touchent 3 168
milles euros et pour 368 euros
c'est un patrimoine de 20,4 millions
d'euros c'est quand même énorme
donc ça profite à une infime minorité
aujourd'hui nous disons que la france va
mal que le peuple de france veut
demeurer admiration vos du travail en a
marre du chômage et nous pensons que ces
cinq ans 458 milles euros of servir à
d'autres choses qu'il ya des privilégiés
quoi vous avez un profité de cette
première journée réservée aux groupes
minoritaires pour proposer cette
proposition de loi
c'est important selon vous de moraliser
la vie financière actuellement
bien sûr quand on voit encore
aujourd'hui que la direction de renault
un met de côté plus de 8 millions
d'actions
1 près de neuf millions d'actions d'une
valeur de 1 612 millions d'euros pour
ses cadres dirigeants
alors que dans le même temps on licencie
dans le même temps passe au chômage
technique est au chômage partiel
il ya quand même une injustice sociale
une injustice fiscale flagrante et cette
france non plus mais n'en veut plus et
il faut changer le cours des choses il
faut que cet argent soit investi
justement au niveau des salaires au
niveau de la production alors que
réellement nous puissions changer le
cours des choses on appris aujourd'hui
que visiblement un décret en sera
publiée pour encadrer les bonus et les
stock options des entreprises aidées par
l'état
ça va dans le bon sens selon vous non
pas forcément pourquoi parce que en 2007
par exemple françois copé qui était
ministre du budget nous annoncer me
disais que ce bouclier fiscal devait
servir à 90000 personnes soit disant des
gens modestes des artisans etc
on est bien vu que c'était faux c'était
totalement faux et que ce bouclier
fiscal a bénéficié qu'à une partie de
privilégiés nous n'y croyions toujours
pas un en ce qui concerne ces décrets
d'autant plus que sous bouclier fiscal
permet aussi de diminuer l'impôt sur la
fortune
c'est pourquoi il faut légiférer bien
sûr nous disons que notre loi est
discutable nous pouvons en discuter
veulent amender
mais il faut légiférer pour justement
mettre les choses clairement s'il
concerne le bouclier fiscal sa
suppression et en ce qui concerne les
rémunérations des grands cadres
dirigeants et puis aussi en ce qui
concerne la question des stocks options
qui aujourd'hui au travers de la france
décrié comme quelque chose de scandaleux
honteux je dois dire que ces gens qui
profitent de celles et de ceux qui
transforment marchandises
le dire ne doivent pas avoir bonne
conscience merci beaucoup
thierry foucaud donc je vous laisse
aller dans l'hémicycle donc où sera
discuté cet après midi je vous le
rappelle la proposition de loi tendant à
abroger le bouclier fiscal bonne séance
à tous mes chers collègues lors du jour
appelle la discussion de la proposition
de loi tendant à abroger le bouclier
fiscal et à moraliser certaines
pratiques des dirigeants des grandes
entreprises en matière de revenus
présentée par monsieur thierry foucaud
et les membres du groupe crc dans la
discussion générale apparent l'état
monsieur sérifou coauteur de la
proposition fois vous avez la parole sur
collègues
bien monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues quelques
mots rapides pour regretter que ce débat
ne puisse se dérouler en présence de
madame la ministre de l'économie et des
finances en plus d'ailleurs quand celle
du ministre du budget compte tenu
d'ailleurs des thèmes de discussion et
de leurs plus récentes déclarations sans
faux procès monsieur le ministre nous
regrettons que l'initiative
parlementaire en matière fiscale ne se
traduise pas par la présence aux bancs
du gouvernement des premiers intéressés
ceux d'ailleurs qui semble montrer le
peu de considération dans lequel on
tient précisément leur représentation
nationale sur un projet sur un texte qui
préoccupe vous savez les françaises et
les français
revenons-en ceci dit au coeur du sujet
qui nous occupe ce jour
quand nous avons déposé le 15 octobre
dernier
cette proposition de loi sur le bouclier
fiscal et les conditions de rémunération
des dirigeants d'entreprise nous ne
pensions pas que ces questions prendrait
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui place
dans le débat politique avec une acuité
toute particulière
voyons si l'une des conséquences de
l'approfondissement d'une crise d'une
crise économique qui apporte chaque jour
son lot de plans sociaux de chômeurs
supplémentaires de réduction d'activité
de fermetures d'entreprises de mise en
cause de la vie quotidienne de centaines
de milliers de salariés et bien sûr de
leur famille confronté à l'incertitude
du lendemain cette crise globale et
mondiale trouve son origine dans les
dérèglements dont les marchés financiers
ont fait l'objet à force de rendre
toujours plus opaques les libre échange
qui s'y déroulaient et de faciliter la
libre et rapide circulation des capitaux
il serait toutefois malhonnête de
limiter la crise que nous connaissons au
sol dérèglement des marchés financiers
moyennant quoi une bonne dose de
régulation et de subi
je dois dire prise de conscience des
organismes financiers internationaux
comme d'ailleurs des banques centrales
suffirait à remettre les choses d'aplomb
la crise recouvre dans chaque pays où
elle se produit des caractères nationaux
fruits notamment du degré de
libéralisation du droit des affaires
comme du travail d'ailleurs mais aussi
des choix budgétaires et fiscaux opéré
depuis de longues années
en ce sens le bouclier fiscal trouve
toute sa place dans ce schéma comme
facteur et fauteurs supplémentaire de
crise parce qu'il correspond au
détournement de l'argent public au
profit exclusif d'une infime poignée de
privilégiés sur la rémunération des
dirigeants
la question qui est posée est également
celle de l'égalité devant l'impôt au
seul motif de la responsabilité à haut
niveau dans telle ou telle entreprise
une infime minorité de quatre salariés
du privé et leur famille parfois je
dirais bénéficient de conditions
privilégiées de rémunération qui les
dispense de s'acquitter de l'impôt au
niveau où cela devrait se produire si
ses revenus se trouvait assimilés à des
salaires la question de l'attractivité
de certains postes de direction
d'entreprises se mesure-t-elle comme
tente de le faire croire
depuis d'ailleurs si longtemps et sous
les prétextes les plus fallacieux
le rapporteur général à la consistance
du parachute doré du plan d'options
d'achat d'actions de la valeur des
actions gratuites ou de la retraite
chapeau dont bénéficient les
bénéficieraient des dirigeants concernés
si tel devait être le cas permettez moi
permettez nous de nous interroger sur la
conscience professionnelle de tels
dirigeants devenus de véritables
chasseurs de primes ce qui semble
clairement établi aujourd'hui et dans la
sphère de la société générale je dirais
jérôme kerviel revient et en même temps
des bonus
faillissent attribué ses dirigeants
c'est que le dispositif des stock
options et toutes les numérations de
cette nature ne vise qu'une seule chose
comment gagner beaucoup d'argent sans
nécessairement méritait de le percevoir
au regard du travail accompli et payer
le moins possible par l'impôt et les
cotisations sociales
oui monsieur le rapporteur général stock
options ou parachutes dorés
ce n'est que cela une magnifique niches
fiscales et sociales réservées à
quelques privilégiés au mépris du
travail des autres et surtout en
profitant du travail des autres
ce sont des obscurs conseiller clientèle
rénumérés au pourcentage qui font le
produit net bancaire de nos deux grandes
banques mais ce produit est appelé à
être largement captée par les dirigeants
dans le sol méritait bien souvent de
seulement dirigé ce sont des ouvriers
des techniciens des cadres qui
conçoivent fabriquent et vendent les
produits de nos grandes entreprises
industrielles et ce sont quelques
dirigeants souvent investis de missions
de représentation qui sont appelés via
leurs stock options et leurs bonus
divers et variés à en tirer parti
pour les uns c'est modération salariale
et intensification continue de la
productivité
pour les autres c'est vive la bourse les
plus values et les dividendes
c'est cela qui est devenu parfaitement
intolérable pour la grande majorité de
la population de notre pays
on ne peut plus dire aux salariés des
entreprises confrontées au chômage
technique comme ceux de renault
sandouville ou de cléon ceux de
continental clairoix monsieur rapporteur
général dont l'entreprise risque la
fermeture de faurecia auchel de good
iranien de films à auxerre de ce de
molex villemur et tant d'autres que
pendant qu'ils accumulent journées de
chômage technique et perte de salaire il
reste en france encore
être que dirigeants de banques et
d'entreprises qui peuvent impunément et
sereinement jouer en bourse
d'ailleurs on apprend encore ce matin
que renault a décidé de provisionner des
stock options pour 2009
je dirais honte honte à l'actionnaire
quel état s'il accepte ce déni de
justice sociale ou demorand permettez
cet aparté mais nos banques et nos plus
grandes entreprises seraient encore
propriété publique
nous n'aurions sans doute pas à
pratiquer la danse du ventre pour les
voir dirigé par quelques financiers et
affairistes à la recherche
je dirais des conditions salariales les
plus avantageuses et donc les plus
dérogatoires du droit commun évidemment
vous allez me dire une fois encore que
depuis 2007 la loi est intervenu à
plusieurs reprises pour fixer le cas de
la rémunération des dirigeants et éviter
toute dérive
mais voilà mes chers collègues qu'il
s'agisse des dispositions de la loi tepa
du code éthique du medef ou de la loi
sur les revenus du travail
tout a volé en éclats entre la sphère
forgeard et celle de la société générale
entre la sphère cheuvreux crédit
agricole
est ce qu'on entend dire sur renault et
valéo mais aussi toutes celles qui vont
sortir dans les jours à venir
ne dites pas que monsieur que messieurs
oudéa et boutons n'ont rien compris ils
ont au contraire très bien compris que
le cadre législatif fixées par les
textes que je viens d'évoquer ne crée
pas de contraintes insurmontable à la
pratique à la poursuite des pratiques
antérieures
il n'ya de notre point de vue une île
justice n'est ni justification
quelconque
qu'un dirigeant d'entreprise puissent
obtenir au tri tre d'une rémunération
accessoires plusieurs centaines deux
fois le salaire moyen des employés de
son entreprise et aux et concevoir des
plans de stock options comme cela se
fait à la société générale ou en crédit
agricole alors même que l'argent public
est venu ces derniers temps vous le
savez renflouer des caisses passablement
asséchées par les errements sur produits
financiers dérivés et de mon point de
vue de notre point de vue celle de notre
groupe parfaitement inacceptable il est
donc temps que de légiférer et de
légiférer vraiment sur la rémunération
des dirigeants d'entreprise
d'autant que la pertinence des stock
options en croire d'ailleurs madame
lagarde commencent d'être mise en cause
dans les primes dans l'esprit même de
celles et de ceux qui les défendent est
jusqu'à il y à peu rappelons que
légiférer sur cette question reviendrait
à s'intéresser à la situation de moins
de 20000 redevables de l'impôt sur le
revenu ce qui représente quelque chose
comme 1 2me millième des contribuables
de cet impôt fondateur de l'égalité
républicaine et de la justice fiscale et
ce régime de faveur coûterait au bas mot
200 à 150 millions d'euros de recettes
fiscales pour l'état
ce sont d'ailleurs peut-être les mêmes
qui sont concernés par le bouclier
fiscal le bouclier fiscal un dispositif
que nous ne pouvons que présentait avec
plus de précision encore à l'occasion de
ce débat nous avons dès lors qu'il a
qu'il en a été question était opposé à
la création de ce dispositif de
remboursement d'impôt dont on avait
prétendu à l'origine qu'il allait
concerner d'abord et avant tout des
ménages modestes mensonge
ainsi monsieur copé
alors ministre du budget avait soutenu
en décembre 2005
je cite il disait en effet sur les 93
mille personnes qui bénéficions de ce
plafonnement près de 90 % sont dans le
premier décide de revenus cela
s'explique par le fait que les impôts
locaux ont été intégrées au bouclier
fiscal c'est un point très important
auquel je tiens beaucoup
cela signifie qu'il s'agit d'une mesure
de justice ce dispositif concernera les
artisans ayant connu une année difficile
les agriculteurs ayant subi une mauvaise
récolte des créateurs d'entreprise bref
un certain nombre de nos compatriotes
qui sont aujourd'hui dans une situation
modeste
je tiens d'ailleurs des simulations à
votre disposition mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs
voilà ce que disait monsieur copé en
décembre 2005 il est juste dommage de
constater au point où nous en sommes que
le nombre de bénéficiaires du bouclier
fiscal n'a jamais atteint le niveau
annoncé en 2005 ce qui pose évidemment
et de manière récurrente la question
même de sa raison d'être au gouvernement
de monsieur sarkozy fillon n'a en effet
alors même qu'il en a encore renforcé le
dispositif en intégrant parce que ça
vous ne le dit jamais assez la cg la
crds et en réduisant le plafond à 50 %
des revenus que 14000 peut-être
misérable contribuables à se mettre sous
la dent et ne voilà-t-il pas de surcroît
que si plus de 8 me de ces contribuables
ont perçu un chèque d'une valeur moyenne
de 535 euros sans doute lié à leur seule
imposition locale
il en est moins de 900 qui se sont vu
accorder un remboursement d'une valeur
moyenne de trois cent soixante huit
mille euros c'est à dire 30 fois le smig
annuel alors je voudrais dire quand même
que pour avoir 3 168 milles euros
il faut quand même déclaré on
un patrimoine de 24 millions d'euros des
données
oui les malheureux 368 1000 euros avec
un patrimoine de 24 millions d'euros des
données d'ailleurs encore plus précises
nous indique d'ailleurs que moi d'une
vingtaine de contribuables auraient
obtenu du trésor public
un remboursement supérieur à 2,5
millions d'euros
dites-nous non résultat comme nous
l'avons dénoncée dans des discussions
budgétaires antérieurs et vous le savez
à chaque discussion budgétaire
d'ailleurs que ce soit au niveau de la
loi de finances initiale comme au moment
du collectif l'essentiel de la dépense
fiscale liée ou bouclier fiscal c'est à
dire l'essentiel des 458 millions
d'euros de perte de recettes qu'il
représente est accaparé par des
contribuables particulièrement riche
je dois dire très riche et pour tout
dire assujetties à l'is f je vais
d'ailleurs vous livrer mon sentiment
c'est bel et bien parce que vous avez
décidé de vous attaquer à l' isf dans la
loi tepa en prenant des mesures
d'allègement sur la valeur de
l'habitation principale ou le
financement des pme que finalement le
bouclier fiscal nous rencontrent
désormais qu'un succès tout relatif
le bouclier fiscal agit quelque part
comme une niche de plus une niche de
trop comme une boursouflure du droit
pour des contribuables dont la situation
est déjà le déjà largement prise en
compte par ailleurs
savez vous comment il faut déclarer de
patrimoine je voulais 10 pour 368 le
roadie sf il faut vanicatte et je crois
qu'il faut a rappelé ce chiffre lorsque
l'on voit cette france qui vit mal
aujourd'hui 360 8000 euros de
récupération 17 10 et 16 24 millions
de patrimoine 24 millions de patrimoine
ses douze à quinze fois le patrimoine
moyen des comptes ryad de l'iace f
et encore ne s'agit-il de ce que je
parlais que du remboursement au titre du
bouclier fiscal
puisqu'on peut penser que des impôts
reste du allez nous expliquer mes chers
collègues que c'est là la réussite que
l'on récompense ce qui est récompensé
ce ne sont que des privilèges acquis par
héritage et qui la plupart du temps
n'ont rien à voir avec la rémunération
du travail et beaucoup avec la position
sociale d'origine
nous n'avons pas à faire la loi pour
quelques affairistes à l'affût de coups
de bourse
mais pour servir l'intérêt général
à la vérité devant son peu de succès
auprès des contribuables
le bouclier fiscal est devenu
indéfendable
il a aujourd'hui tous les travers d'une
énorme niches fiscales au profit d'une
infime minorité de contribuables de
liesse f
notre proposition de loi a le mérite de
la simplicité la suppression du bouclier
fiscal dispositif inopérant sans impact
économique avérée superfétatoire est une
nécessité objectif en ces temps de crise
où la grande majorité des françaises et
des français doivent se serrer la
ceinture alors tiré le bilan de la
pratique et oser oser pour une fois
revenir sur ce que vous avez voté et
pourquoi certains concèdent aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs avoir été abusé supprimons
ensemble second pilier fiscale la mise
en cause aussi des stock options et
autres rémunérations dérogatoire dans un
contexte de pressions continues est
renforcée sur les salaires est du même
ordre
la faillite je dirais d'un système
économique où la richesse créée par le
travail a été et cela au fil du temps
de plus en plus capté par le capital et
bien sûr ses dérivés est patente et
imposent de repenser l'organisation
économique comme notre système fiscal
sur des bases nouvelles
cette proposition de loi que nous vous
invitons à adopter en constitue une
première étape
modeste assez fortement symbolique mais
néanmoins nécessaire il est temps de
rendre à l'impôt toutes ces vertus
républicaines et de faire contribuer
justement chacune et chacun en fonction
de ses possibilités à l'oeuvre commune
le redressement économique
mes chers collègues au redressement
économique du pays passe aussi par les
mesures que nous vous proposons ici
d'adopter
je vous remercie chers collègues la
parole et à monsieur le rapporteur
général
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
cette proposition de loi s'inscrit dans
le cadre de la séance mensuelle réservé
aux initiatives des groupes politiques
d'opposition et des groupes minoritaires
nous sommes tous des minoritaires dans
cette assemblée
selon les nouvelles dispositions de
l'article 48 alinéa 5 de la constitution
jusque là rien à vie alors le groupe
communistes républicains et citoyens et
les sénateurs du parti de gauche met
l'accent sur un sujet important et
délicat
il convient de souligner comme l'a fait
à plusieurs reprises le président de la
république dans son discours de toulon
le 25 septembre puis cette semaine dans
son discours de saint-quentin que le
fait d'occuper des responsabilités
économiques éminente crée des devoirs je
crois devoir le répéter à mon tour au
début de ce rapport
lorsqu'on a le talent lorsqu'on a la
chance de diriger des hommes des femmes
et c'est une haute mission de diriger il
convient d'être très attentif à
l'environnement économique et social et
de faire preuve de bon sens et il est
des périodes où l'esprit public en effet
est à juste titre très sensibles aux
questions de rémunération et aux
avantages annexes aux rémunérations dans
la vieille société ont pratiqué le
principe bien connu dans nos provinces
pour vivre heureux vivons cachés
on n'aimait pas étaler la richesse et
plus on était riche
- on le montrait dans la société
d'aujourd'hui et dans le monde globalisé
on estime parfois de voir apparaître la
société devenue une société d'apparence
et parmi les apparences
parmi eux c'est ces choses qui brillent
il y a en particulier certains avantages
annexes aux rémunérations et mes chers
collègues c'est bien le contexte dans
lequel nous traitons de la présente
proposition de loi la commission des
finances qui m'a confié ce rapport
m'inciter à regarder avec beaucoup de
précision les sept articles de la
proposition de loi
et comme on peut l'observer en se
référant à mon rapport écrit
l'analyse a été approfondi
toutefois la matière dont nous traitons
n'est pas strictement nouvelle car il
faut rappeler que dans chacune de nos
discussions budgétaires de ces derniers
mois les sujets dont nous allons traiter
cet après midi sont revenus avec
insistance les arguments que nous avons
échangé l'ont déjà été dans cet
hémicycle à de nombreuses reprises vous
ne serez donc pas surpris mes chers
collègues que je vous dise que la
commission dans sa majorité appelle au
rejet des différents articles de la
proposition mais rejet motive
et argumentée et la séance de cet après
midi va nous permettre à nouveau de
confronter nos différents arguments
telle est la règle normale dans un monde
pluraliste et au sein d'une assemblée
comme la nôtre la suppression pure et
simple du bouclier fiscal remettrait en
cause un dispositif qui souhaite éviter
le caractère confiscatoire de l'impôt
les chiffres de l'administration fiscale
confirme l'utilité de ce dispositif tel
qu'il a été retouchée par la loi de
l'été 2007
deux tiers des quatorze mille foyers
fiscaux bénéficiaires du bouclier sont
des foyers à revenus très modestes mais
possédant leur résidence principale et
pour qui le poids de la taxe foncière
peut être difficilement supportable
néanmoins mes chers collègues vous le
savez la commission des finances a à de
nombreuses reprises exposé ces derniers
mois que le bouclier fiscal n'est pas
sans reproche
mais s'il n'est pas sans reproche
c'est parce qu'il est un dispositif
dérivé d'un autre l'impôt de solidarité
sur la fortune
je voudrais rappeler que nous avons jean
arthuis
jean pierre fourcade et moi même lors de
la discussion de la loi de finances pour
2009 soumis à notre haute assemblée un
amendement que j'appelle la trilogie et
qui comportait la suppression du
bouclier fiscal
l'abrogation de l'impôt sur la fortune
et la création en contrepartie et à due
concurrence démentant ainsi abandonné
par le budget la création d'une nouvelle
tranche d'impôt sur le revenu
cette disposition
ou plus exactement cette trilogie
devront s'appliquer un jour ou l'autre
c'est manifestement la solution pour
autant pour autant mais je parle d'une
perspective plus longue pour autant
tenir tenir des débats de stratégie
fiscale en pleine crise ne paraît
vraiment pas très opportun pas très
réaliste car mes chers collègues nous
sommes dans une phase où nécessairement
les jalousies sont exacerbées et par
ailleurs tout débat de politique fiscale
risque soin d'apparaître comme
provocateur soit d'aboutir à un
alourdissement de la fiscalité qui
serait un handicap supplémentaire au
moment où la récession est ce qu'elle
est il est tout à fait clair qu'à
l'avenir en sortie de crise nous serons
toujours et peut-être même encore
davantage dans un monde ouvert où les
compétences devront circuler ou les
entreprises devront faire appel aux
talents et les payer au prix du marché
qu'on le veuille ou non et que mais
c'est une réalité
et personne ne propose un modèle de
repli derrière des frontières personnes
à quelques endroits qu'on se situent nos
eux-mêmes décrire ce que pourrait être
ce modèle donc n'ayant aucune espèce
d'illusion l'attractivité du territoire
et l'attractivité fiscale en particulier
demeurera un objectif incontournable de
la politique fiscale en sortie de crise
et lorsque notre économie aura retrouvé
le chemin de la croissance
venons en à présent aux politiques de
rémunération j'ai évoqué au début des
considérations morales des
considérations de comportement qui
devrait s'imposer à l'esprit de tous
et plus particulièrement à l'esprit de
celles et ceux qui ont les plus hautes
responsabilités dans le monde économique
pour autant est-il raisonnable
d'imaginer un plafonnement général de
tout ou partie des rémunérations
une suppression ou l'impossibilité de
mettre en place des mécanismes
d'associations au capital des dirigeants
et des mandataires sociaux des
entreprises
il est clair qu'elle est aussi loin
comme le propose le présent texte
ce serait nous créer des handicaps
particulièrement lourd pour demain et
pour après demain dans la compétition
internationale je voudrais rappeler que
le législateur auquel nous participons
est loin d'avoir été inactif ces
dernières années
au contraire il est intervenu sur tous
ces sujets à de nombreuses reprises afin
d'encadrer des pratiques d'améliorer le
contrôle des actionnaires de garantir la
transparence et d'aller dans le sens
d'une certaine justice sociale
je peux rappeler que la loi du 3
décembre 2008 relative aux revenus du
travail a subordonné l'attribution
d'options de souscription d'achat
d'actions aux mandataires sociaux à la
distribution des mêmes options ou
d'actions gratuites à l'ensemble des
salariés de l'entreprise ou à la mise en
oeuvre d'un dispositif d'intéressement
ou de participation volontaire ou
dérogatoire c'est une disposition
importante qui consiste à partager à
l'échelle la plus large dans l'ensemble
de l'entreprise
cet intéressement à l'éventuelle plus
value sur le capital
je rappellerai aussi que la loi de
finances pour 2009 a modifié le régime
fiscal des parachutes dorés en
plafonnant le montant des indemnités de
départ déductible du bénéfice imposable
à six fois le plafond annuel de la
sécurité sociale
je rappellerai que la loi du 21 août
2007 6 vilipendé par certains
malgré ses évidentes qualités a interdit
les éléments de rémunération indemnités
et avantages dont le bénéfice n'est pas
subordonnée au respect de conditions
liées aux performances du bénéficiaire
appréciée au regard de celle de la
société et ses performances
elles peuvent et doivent être constatée
est attestée par des éléments précis et
chiffrés qu'il appartient aux assemblées
générales et au conseil d'administration
de constater et de faire respecter
permettez moi aussi mes chers collègues
de citer la loi du 30 décembre 2006 pour
le développement de la participation et
de l'actionnariat salarié qui a encadré
les modalités de rémunération des
dirigeants mandataires sociaux en
prévoyant que le rapport de gestion des
sociétés cotées doit présenter les
principes et les règles arrêtées par le
conseil d'administration ou de
surveillance pour déterminer les
rémunérations et avantages de toute
nature accordés aux mandataires sociaux
ce même texte impose aux sociétés de
définir des obligations de conservation
sur tout ou partie des titres attribués
aux dirigeants et ce jusqu'à la
cessation de leurs fonctions
enfin la loi dite breton du 27 juillet
vous regrettez cette période non a
notablement renforcée
les obligations de transparence des
sociétés cotées
en soumettant au régime des conventions
réglementées les éléments de
rémunération versée à raison de deux ou
posters humains ou postérieurement à la
cessation des fonctions des dirigeants
l'application de ce régime implique pour
ce que l'on peut appeler les retraites
chapeaux les indemnités de départ les
parachutes dorés une autorisation
préalable du conseil d'administration ou
de surveillance l'information des
commissaires aux comptes
la soumission de ces conventions à
l'approbation de l'assemblée générale
des actionnaires
je rappelle en tout dernier lieu qu'en
cas de perception de rémunérations
excessives ou interdites
le bénéficiaire expose non seulement sa
responsabilité civile mais aussi sa
responsabilité pénale sur le chef d'abus
de biens sociaux
si les éléments constitutifs de cette
infraction sort et il me semble
important d'insister sur la
responsabilisation de l'ensemble des
acteurs du gouvernement d'entreprise et
je conclurai sur ce thème si vous me le
permettez la moralisation des pratiques
de rémunération des dirigeants et des
mandataires sociaux relève
je persiste à le dire d'abord de la
responsabilisation de l'autodiscipline
des mandataires sociaux qui ne doivent
pas vivre dans une bulle
mais dans la réalité sociale de leur
pays d'aujourd'hui
parallèlement au renforcement du cadre
législatif
il existe depuis plusieurs années une
volonté d'élaborer des règles de
conduite de les faire prévaloir et nous
savons que de la part des pouvoirs
publics
la demande est forte pour parvenir à des
normes encore plus précises mieux
élaborés et qu'ils soient davantage
opposable aux dirigeants et aux
mandataires sociaux
des entreprises de nouvelles
recommandations sur la rémunération des
dirigeants mandataires sociaux dans les
sociétés cotées ont été proposées en
octobre 2008 convient certainement
d'aller plus loin et il est important je
crois de bien identifier une situation
particulière qui est celle des
entreprises aidées par l'état en vue de
faire face à la crise qu'il s'agisse du
financement du secteur bancaire qu'il
s'agisse du financement des filières
automobile
qu'il s'agisse des plans sociaux aidés
financièrement par la collectivité
oui il semble tout à fait logique et
normal que ces aides comporte des
conditionnalités à la vérité on
appliquerait la ce qui s'applique au
plan international
quand un état vient trouver le fonds
monétaire international
l'aide lui est alloué moyennant un
certain nombre de conditions qui vont
dicter son comportement pour une
entreprise c'est exactement la même
chose si un groupe bancaire a besoin du
concours de l'état pour opérer son
refinancement ou pour renforcer ses
fonds propres
si un groupe présent dans la filière
automobile a besoin de se faire aider
par des concours temporaire de l'état il
est logique
il est normal que des conditionnalités
préval et qu'elles conduisent les
dirigeants à souscrire à une discipline
a plus encore de transparence et à une
modération de leurs comportements
salariaux et relatifs aux différents
éléments annexes aux rémunérations
nous allons prendre connaissance dans
les jours qui viennent
deux dispositions de cette nature et
elle me semble à titre personnel apporté
une réponse plus raisonnable plus
équilibrée aux préoccupations
d'aujourd'hui que ce n'est le cas dans
la proposition de loi de nos excellents
collègues du groupe communiste
républicain et citoyen et des sénateurs
du parti de gauche
dans ce contexte vous comprendrez que
notre commission soit peu favorable
c'est une litote à l'adoption des
dispositions préconisées par la
proposition de loi les attitudes
vertueuses doivent être encouragées et
soutenues voire initiée par les pouvoirs
publics
néanmoins le texte qui nous est proposé
n'est pas une réponse correctement
dimensionné c'est un texte qui créerait
des dégâts économiques encore plus grave
dans notre pays et pour l'ensemble de
ces raisons vous le comprendrez la
commission des finances appellent au
rejet des différents articles qui
composent cette proposition de gua mes
chers collègues je vous remercie de
m'avoir écouté
remercie monsieur le rapporteur général
la parole est à monsieur andré santini
secrétaire d'état chargé de la fonction
publique
vous avez la parole monsieur le ministre
ce président est monsieur le président
de la commission des finances monsieur
le rapporteur général mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs
cette proposition de loi du groupe
communiste républicain et citoyen et des
sénateurs du parti de gauche vise à
abroger le bouclier fiscal et prétend
moraliser certaines pratiques des
dirigeants de grandes entreprises
disons le tout de suite cette
proposition ne répond pas de façon
adéquate aux problèmes qui ont été
soulevés par un certain nombre d'abus
récent que le président de la république
est d'ailleurs condamné avant-hier à
saint-quentin ni d'une manière générale
aux problèmes que connaît actuellement
notre pays
l'article premier s'est dit clairement
l'article premier de votre proposition
de loi vise à supprimer le bouclier
fiscal sur ce sujet le discours du
gouvernement n'a pas varié changer de
cap en pleine crise n'arrangerait rien
je sais que l'opposition souhaite faire
du bouclier fiscal
un point de fixation du débat public
politique et cette proposition de loi en
est le témoignage
mais la politique du gouvernement ne se
réduit pas au bouclier fiscal
vous ne pouvez pas tordre les chiffres
pour les besoins d'une communication
politique le bouclier fiscal de 2008
mesurait au 12 février 2009
dernière date dont j'ai les chiffres
sait on l'a dit 458 millions d'euros
soit 7 milliards 7 de la loi dite tepa
entendons nous bien le bouclier fiscal
c'est 6% ne t'ai pas à plus le paquet
fiscal c'est d'abord des mesures pour le
plus grand nombre
or supplémentaires crédit d'impôt pour
emprunts immobiliers mais surtout je
voudrais mettre les pieds dans le plat
et la firme est nettement un
plafonnement des impôts directs à 50%
c'est tout d'abord une mesure juste
c'est même une règle de valeur
constitutionnelle chez plusieurs de nos
voisins
il s'agit d'éviter qu'on travaille plus
d'un jour sur
deux pour l'état il est tout à fait
contre productif de chercher à
stigmatiser des contribuables qui
exercent leur droit à restitution
ce sont des personnes qui ont un
remboursement total de 458 millions
d'euros mais qui avait préalablement
payé plus de 1 milliard 100 euros
d'impôts et même pour les 834
contribuables qui concentrent 307
millions d'euros de remboursements que
l'opposition a choisi de singulariser
dans les données qui ont été transmises
aux commissions des finances de
l'assemblée par eric woerth cela ont
initialement payé 5 185 millions d'euros
soit à peu près le montant de leurs
revenus
si on veut les faire partir dans un
monde où le capital et mobiles ou les
personnes sont mobiles leur prélever
plus de la moitié de leur revenu est
exactement ce qu'il faut faire
on voit d'ailleurs que le bouclier
fiscal un impact positif de ce point de
vue en 2007
écoutez bien ce chiffre que vous ne
citez pas assez les départs du
territoire ont baissé de 15%
les retours ont augmenté de 10% ce coup
de frein au départ c'est la première
fois depuis 2000 quand on observe ce
n'est pas un hasard si c'est la première
année de mise en oeuvre du bouclier
fiscal
on observe je remarque d'ailleurs que
les deux tiers des bénéficiaires du
bouclier fiscal sont des personnes
modestes qui perçoivent un revenu
inférieur à 1000 euros par mois surtout
ce que je dis est vrai je comprends je
comprendre ça vous heurte mais c'est
cependant la statistique risque
surtout et j'aimerais que l'on cesse un
instant la politique politicienne la
démagogie pour en convenir
tous ensemble il y avait dans ce pays
deux offense à la justice fiscale de
péché contre l'esprit
le premier s'était en effet que l'on
puisse payer plus de 50% de son revenu
et parfois même 100 % ou plus en impôts
annuels cela n'existe pas ailleurs ou
l'imposition sur la fortune a été
progressivement supprimés en france nous
sommes les derniers à l'avoir conservée
mais en dépit de tous les démagogues
il fallait en responsabilité garantir
que cela ne conduise pas à des
prélèvements confiscatoire nous l'avons
fait nous avons eu raison le
gouvernement le revendique
le second péché contre l'esprit vous
permettrait de penser qu'un péché contre
l'esprit ça vous interpelle quand même
le second péché contre l'esprit celui
contre lequel personne n'avait trouvé de
solution avant cette législature c'est
que la multiplication et le
déplafonnement de certaines niches
fiscales permettaient à des
contribuables de s'exonérer complètement
d'impôt sur le revenu
fin 2008 nous avons enfin mis en oeuvre
un plafonnement effectifs des niches
fiscales
nous l'avons fait nous avons eu raison
c'est cela que le gouvernement
revendique le vrai scandale
ce n'est pas qu'un citoyen dans ce pays
ne paye que 50% d'impôts le vrai
scandale c'est que jusqu'ici on pouvait
en payer zéro cette vérité aussi
j'aimerais que tout le monde s'attachent
à la rappeler je ne nie pas qu'on puisse
avoir une réflexion d'ensemble sur la
fiscalité du patrimoine que le conseil
des prélèvements obligatoires dans son
dernier rapport a jugée lourde plus
lourde que chez nos voisins d'ailleurs
mais cette réflexion il faudra l'a menée
de façon complète à froid et pas en
période de crise votre article 2 vise à
confisquer aux dirigeants par un impôt
au taux de 100 %
les indemnités de départ excédant deux
cent cinquante mille euros nets
l'entreprise qui se risqueraient à
verser une indemnité pourtant ainsi
fisc et seraient soumises à une taxe
supplémentaire dont les modalités ne
sont pas précisés l'article 3 a pour
objet de taxer à 100% toute rémunération
liée à l'évolution de cours boursiers je
pense que vous visez la les
stock-options et les actions gratuites
le gouvernement n'est pas favorable à
ces deux propositions je m'en explique
en premier lieu une réponse strictement
fiscal ne me paraît pas aujourd'hui la
mieux adaptée
les indemnités versées aux dirigeants à
l'occasion de la cessation de leurs
fonctions sont en effet par principe
imposable elles ne sont exonérés par
exception et sous plafond que lorsque
cette cessation revêt un caractère forcé
ces dispositions assure un traitement
équilibré des indemnités de départ des
dirigeants qui ne sont exonérés que si
elles sont versées dans des conditions
qui les rapprochent de celles prévues
pour l'exonération d'indemnités de
licenciement des salariés mais surtout
gouvernement a pris des mesures depuis
deux ans pour moraliser la rémunération
des dirigeants
dès août 2007 l'article 17 de la loi
tepa à renforcer drastiquement
l'encadrement des parachutes dorés des
dirigeants des sociétés cotées
ce nouveau dispositif impose à peine de
nullité
la fixation de conditions performance
conditionnant le versement d'indemnités
de départ le respect d'une procédure
contraignante qui va au delà de la
procédure classique d'approbation et
conventions réglementées la publicité
des décisions du conseil
d'administration autorisant les
engagements et la publicité des
décisions constatant la réalisation des
conditions de performance le régime
juridique ainsi mis en place permet déjà
de garantir que les indemnités de départ
des dirigeants ne leur sont pas indûment
versées mais récompense bien leurs
performances
vous venez de suivre la discussion
générale sur la proposition de loi
tendant à abroger le bouclier fiscal
merci de votre attention et à très
bientôt sur public sénat